allez latin savoir qui de beauté alors
je vous dire de l'année prochaine dans
tpm plein de surprises et peut-être même
les nouveaux chroniqueurs vous savez
dans cette émission je vous dit tout
donc le casting je veux faire passer
devant vous alors premiers candidats
pour l'année prochaine mechri plein d'or
ces bouquins ferrer c'est cyril lignac
qu'oussama cyril lignac supersilent moi
je lui propose il ne chronique bien
gourmand dit jean luc lemoine il fait
déjà les questions en 4/3
donc moi comme je suis un bon pâtissier
un peu de farine et ne peut donner un
peu de sucre et un peu d'humour
je vais faire les questions en 4/4
george honos du futur je vous dis le
gari vis de sarkozy en prison doit aller
deuxième candidat est le shérif pour
l'année prochaine je l'adoré c'est mon
préféré c'est gérard wolf sa beauté oui
oui sert il je vous entends très bien
c'est normal gérard vous êtes juste à
côté de moi ah oui effectivement
bonsoir seriez là alors je pense que je
ferai un très bon chroniqueur qu'elle
pas mon poste l'année prochaine puisque
son votre émission
c'est un peu comme le tour de france
sauf que ce sont les audiences qui sont
dopés par les coureurs arriveront pas
son candidat suivant c'est mon préféré
assez au jeu je l'adoré
cela doit cesser christophe mali et le
ghana le gars le gars le gars
bonjour tout le monde
alors moi j'ai envie de faire une
chronique musicale spéciale tpm paix et
ça donne ça mais qu'est ce qu'on est
serrée avant le site de boîte
j'adore j'adore alors s'il adore patrick
sébastien ont 85 ans olympiens n'étaient
pas des biens tranche numéro un cherry a
terminé avec quelqu'un que j'adore alors
lui c'est mon préféré
il est magnifique les chocs pour le
france du 100 m c'est christophe
lemaitre à ces derniers candidats
commencent à christophe vous voulez pas
parler christophe basset maire n'avait
pas dit à vos marques prêts partez
je sais pas quand tout a commencé alors
christophe alors vous vous proposez de
quoi comme chronique l'année prochaine 1
à vos marques prêts partez
voici la chronique va et son plateau à
frau se trouve que le comte claus quoi
j'ai pas derrière vous le courant soit à
fond à fond à fond
ils ont enfin à vos pinceaux pour 93 100
points de france à la chronique battus
vraiment critique m